[Music]
so happy adjourn here
after my parents died and I didn't
really think I was gonna be able to come
back to Tijuana but you always made me
feel like family you are my family
[Music]
[Music]
yeah Marik mamas and I just want to find
my friend I need you to do a favor for
me first
you mess around I'll kill you both
to park the car real close to the curb
you see you have to believe me they made
me do it the building that you blew up
the DEA safe house you know how long you
go away for unless you help us you know
Esparza
see you buddy forget your friends who's
coming to save you whether or not you
survive
entirely up to you
you're gonna be my you gotta learn how
to use one of these a viola bullet
balleseros everything ever since you
showed up the police in one step ahead
you better do what you need to do Delano
has a mole in his operation
[Applause]
lies
I'm not giving up on my family
nabela
in the end
the bullet settles everything
[Music]
Estes when I rode your solo career and
good
tell me lies I'm gonna hurt you okay
y-you were the DA no you talk like a
pork chop what's your deal come from the
states
I live here for a few years my father is
American and he owned a factory of
luckylove I hear yours in my kia ora
it's gone your father gone too
I can help you find your friend what do
you have to do something for me first do
that and I hope you find solution you
mess around I'll kill you both
[Music]
all right stay with uh put your clunky
before the light
[Music]
I'm right on this corner hard to call
real close to the curb take your phone
and meet us up the hill
Abdulla driving back there I have begun
radio check this out Chula
[Music]
turn it off
open it up
where's the rest come on in you take the
van
I need to get a message to lino are you
listening I want you to tell her Jimmy
said the DA has a mole and his operation
you got America hands I just want to
find my family
I went hard in this film this
transformation was the most dedicated
the most disciplined I've ever been both
ice Jane the Virgin the character that I
worked on the majority of the year had a
different body structure than my
character Gloria I got very disciplined
very focused so in these things
explosive the stunt scene has to perform
I am an adrenaline junkie I
funds
drive crazy cars
and run across big huge parking lots
back and forth 80-plus times
Lauria ends up evolving from a very
ordinary who very extraordinary TV I
could do it I could do anything that's
not true
this film has been quite the writer die
for me
[Music]
you